so if Pablo Neruda had a Twitter account
what hashtags would have used do you
think oh you would poetry for sure but
America probably socialism yes come on
Ethan yeah do you think today's
persecuted artists or folk heroes are
less about ideology and it's more about
whistleblowers Julian Assange Snowden's
even some of the hacktivists that expose
corporate fraud do you think it's less
about because now with social media
anybody can put their ideologies out
there in most countries exactly the pins
were no the pens wearing the pins
Halbert but it is it is incredible that
that in both cases the system in a way
organizes and and really like you know
just puts together a lot of energy and
resources to shut down one person and
this is something that happens in in
this film there is a big movement you
know of you know we'll worry to shut
down one person and that's something
that's been happening throughout it's
quite astonishing how how it is
impossible also to shut down my presence
thoughts know and and if today's people
is using social media or they're hacking
information from organizations
government or whatever
what Neruda was doing as he was doing
she was using poetry he was using poetry
to communicate his ideologist
perspectives and and he points of view
and on how to change the world
throughout poetry so it's nice to go
back a little bit use the time machine
that cinema can have and see how you
know not long ago
it's just 60 years ago our poets were
trying to change the world through our
words and through poetry on metaphors
and I think this a little bit do I have
a quote from him and it says it was my
destiny to love and say goodbye and
that's from still another day that scene
so tame compared to what anybody can put
out there on social media today what do
you feel about that I mean I know for
you growing up in Mexico you said that
there were no autonomous voices at the
time in the media but were there any
folk heroes the two of you had any
persecuted artists that were similar to
Pablo Neruda mm-hmm
that's persecuted I don't know I mean in
my country at 17 years of dictatorship
and many many artists were assassinated
tortured exiled shut down I mean there's
a bunch of people in in my country I
couldn't talk about it in Mexico but I'm
sure in in Argentina and Brazil and
other countries that also had elected to
shape I think yeah of course Faison has
done a lot of that much to our cultural
activity in America so I could them in
your field but unfortunately there's
thousands of them yeah there is a poet I
mean I'm speaking for like maybe a
generational kind of scope but there is
a poet that and he's also an amazing
songwriter I mean an amazing musician
amazing guitarist called Sylvia
Rodriguez who definitely shaped a lot of
people's I don't know lives when we were
young and and he it's not that he was
persecuted it's just that him being
Cuban many countries don't even listen
to him yeah and he's a you know
wonderful nation yeah wonderful
galactic